like most Big City Mayors Myrtle Bowser
of Washington DC has made life for her
own residence much much worse over the
past couple of years but the same time
she's shown great concern for illegal
aliens coming here she declared
Washington DC a sanctuary City she said
the city would pay to fight the federal
government's efforts to deport people
she said the city would give illegal
aliens Free Housing Health Care
education
well
why wouldn't people from around the
world take Muriel Bowser up on her offer
well they have and they've moved there
in huge numbers that's a win for
diversity right no turns out mirrorless
Bowser is and we don't use this phrase
lightly a white supremacist maybe even a
white nationalist
she's claiming this new diversity in
Washington DC is a humanitarian crisis
and she's such a racist she wants the
Army to come
watch I've asked for the deployment of
the guard as long as we need the guard
to deal with the humanitarian crisis
that we expect to escalate the number of
people crossing the border seeking
Asylum we expect to only go up
and we need to make sure that there is a
national response
chip Roy is a congressman from Texas
who's been to the Border numerous times
we're happy to talk to him tonight
Congressman thanks so much for coming on
so we're obviously making fun of Muriel
Bowser who's one of the most incompetent
people ever to hold public office in
this country on the other hand she is
calling out the National Guard to deal
with illegal aliens why aren't the
governors of real States doing that
actually now that I think about it
well you know Tucker it's interesting
here in the mayor of Washington DC which
is where I'm sitting right now
complaining about 4 000 people on 200
buses that Governor Abbott has sent to
Washington D.C since April running to
the Pentagon saying oh my gosh we need
the National Guard oh well you know what
Cry Me a freaking river right you know
welcome to the party pal in down in
Texas today in the Border we're going to
have about 7 000 people crossing the
border across the entire Southwest
border and about half of that in Texas
Crimea River about the I don't know 50
bodies in a mobile morgue in Brooks
County Texas where Sheriff Benny
Martinez is having to deal with dead
migrants all over the ranches talk to
the families that are you know concerned
about the people packing pistols like
this guy this illegal immigrant on a
ranch that I just got this picture about
an hour ago from the County Attorney at
Kinney County Texas that's what we're
dealing with every day so welcome to the
party pal I don't want to really hear
all your complaining and you want to
talk about racism how about the racism
about a uh DHS that is forcing these
border patrol agents to be be accused of
whipping Haitians and being called
racist with a completely unfounded
charge I'm just sick of this garbage
well I am too I agree with that
completely Congressman chip Roy of Texas
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight